this is a production of cornell
university
my video background is actually
a virtual background for our second
global sustainability
conference which just finished today and
this continued the theme that we've been
discussing
uh well for a couple of years now in in
the event the associated
partners uh really how to move
this entire industry how it's a whole
new more sustainable industry including
making sustainability part of the core
business and not just
some green washing or corporate social
responsibility
so a lot of what i'm going to talk about
is coming from that
anger but of course i'm looking at
it also from the point of view of signs
in a sense that
i've spent my entire career until now or
the recently
30 years in essentially public sector
research
and so i think it's the marriage of
science and
and industry thinking that interests me
nowadays
because i think that in the end will
hopefully make a difference
so this new paradigm that i will talk
about is not entirely new
but i think what is new is that
we we have now also this thinking
penetrating
across the industry uh for those who
don't know
either so if our current current name is
international fertilizer association
it had a few other names in the past
because it's very early but
founded in 1927 and it is in fact the
only
global fertilizer industry association
so we have members that
produce fertilizers but also members who
just trade it or distribute it
or members who do everything including
more done
stream services to farmers but we also
have
non-industry members so research
institutes several sdg centers
or for example remember rothenstein
and a number of other associations and
ngos
we have at present about 450 something
like that
members in various categories across the
world
and they represent let's say about 80
percent of the global fertilizer
production
now when you look at our vision and
mission
it's already stated there that we
we're not a lobbying organization we
want to
promote the efficient and responsible
production distribution and use of plant
nutrition
and so through that we'll hopefully make
it a contribution to
more sustainable agriculture in the
world so this is
stated already for quite some time but
i think it also goes back to the
fundamental story
of modern agriculture and fertilizer so
this is the slide from our awesome step
time which i like doing because
on one side it pretty much summarizes
what has happened in one way or another
in different
reincarnations throughout the world in
the last
150 or so years now and what's
interesting is that
the value of nutrients as a whole and
the fertilizer in particular
was already demonstrated in this
experiment 175 years ago
i mean you can see that in this graph
there are
the two lines here the pink one or
whatever the color is here in this dark
violet one here are the ones with
nutrient input
one is manure formula manure in those
days
and the other one is a full dose of
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium and a
few other things
and you can see that uh with just by
doing this
you could triple years already back in
the
19th century and that's what it was for
a long time
until after 1960 roughly speaking
we had the general ingredients of the
green revolution
that are also shown in this graffia
where you can see
years rapidly going up in continuous
wheat here
up to about six seven tons nowadays
due to the short straw varieties capella
was the first one that came in high
yielding stuff
but if you moved to wheat and going on
rotation
you could then also double digits
further and nowadays
harassing routinely about 12 tons of
years in this experiment
and there's a success of other
succession of other changes the
technologies that took place and the
fertilizer i think as we all know
has been produced a key ingredient of
this training revolution but also
actually a driver for many other things
and too
and vice versa so it's a never-ending
succession of
technology and this has happened
throughout the world
now my entry into agriculture happened
in 1977 you know when i was a
16 year old young boy i guess you know
in east germany and decided to
embark on a three-year apprenticeship
and you could learn in those there's a
profession that
was called agricultural chemist or argo
chemist
these were times when we all got excited
about these things you know
i actually drove all of these machines
so that you can see on this slide except
for this airplane because
uh you needed special security
clearances was a very popular means for
escaping the west germany and only a few
people could
fly it so but all of the other ones i
did
and it was the time when young people
got very excited about
modern agriculture because you got to
drive big
fancy machines and you didn't really
worry too much about what we
what we were doing so what we were
actually spraying or spreading on these
fields it all seemed right and was
the spirit of time to increase yields as
you may notice the
further out of spreaders and those days
even made it onto postage stamps in this
country you know
i can imagine trying this today so this
is how i got into this yeah there was a
if you now
look back you can see that right away in
the middle
of this green revolution or
intensification that took place uh also
in europe in irrespective of whether you
lived a capitalist or a communist
country it happened everywhere
so the problem with this approach
obviously
was that we have
created a world that nowadays from a
nutrient point of view looks like this
so it's essentially a global nutrient
imbalance which you can see
for many nutrients but particularly for
nitrogen but also for phosphorus to some
degree
in the same way so we have uh
large surpluses in some parts of the
world you can see that in
china for example northern india over
here
parts of europe parts of north america
and now also emerging
in parts and south america
and we have on the other hand huge part
of the world
in which we have deficits
or at best very small surpluses
which essentially also neutral balances
and these situations essentially
mean that you're mining the solar for
nutrients this whole picture got of
course
further exaggerated through the emerging
ongoing international trade of food and
feed items
and the new trends along with this and
so we've really
created a situation now that is not easy
to correct
so on one side and surpluses that create
massive environmental issues of that
kind
and then the other side deficits or
no applications that
create environmental problems and
human problems of other kinds so this is
the real issue that we are facing and
i think this is now
my observation also sinking in very much
into industry uh and not just now but
probably already for quite a few years
so this is a slide
that i took from a yara investors
relations seminar and given by the yara
ceo
in december i have a link down here
where you can watch the
seminar it's actually very interesting
to watch
in which she essentially lays out
how yara as one of the world's leading
fertilizer companies is trying to
transform itself from originally being
essentially an
asset producer who just stole what they
produced
back in the early 20th century then
developing more own products and
building a reputation
and then in more recent times moving on
to
a more crop focused approach and more
farmer-centric solutions so becoming a
crop nutrition company rather than just
a producer company or commodity producer
and that next stage is essentially to
move on
to climate neutral solutions and
throughout the entire nutrient plane
from
the way you produce things on
fertilizers in this particular case
you how you use them including
recycling of things so this is a massive
transformation and it's not happening on
its own
it's very much a business need nowadays
so it's driven by another by an
investor pressure besides the public and
societal pressure that always exists
but also i think increasingly driven by
employees
essentially employees in the company who
want
companies to become more sustainable
businesses you
you need to pay attention to this too
so i could show similar ambitions for a
number of the world's leading food
advancer companies
but i just want to make the point here
that this is not a one of thing
this has become ingrained now in
the industry and it's very interesting
to watch this
particularly for someone like me who has
been acting interacting with the
industry for about 25 years
and always has complained about a lot of
sort of stagnation
and unwillingness to innovate but
this is now a much more interesting time
so in this process a few years ago ether
did a number of exercises a vision
exercise and then
two years ago nearly two years ago
we had our first high level forum one
and a half years ago
in which this was spelled out further
and there was for the first time the
mentioning of the word okay
moving out a new paradigm for
sustainable plant nutrition
and it was phrased from the industry
perspective at that time as
okay productivity and food security are
still
very critical needs to not neglect
because we still have these issues in
many parts of the world and the world
population is growing
but a new paradigm for plant nutrition
must
embrace a food systems approach with all
of its sustainability dimensions
including greenhouse gas emissions
reduction pollution biodiversity
waste and nutrient recycling and
nutrition and health
so and then this document which you can
download if you want uh
more discussion is made about okay what
could be specific things that industry
can do and what others need to be done
need to get done so but it was an eye
opener
and we have since then continued this
process so
earlier uh last year in
early 2020 we set up a new
think tank which is called the
scientific panel on responsible plant
nutrition
or sbrpn and the first task
that in this think tank that we set
ourselves was
can we think about elaborating a bit
more
also from a scientific point of view
about this new paradigm for blood
nutrition
what what what are the key issues that
it needs to address
what can be done about those who need to
do what and
what in principle would success look
like within
sort of a human generation time frame
so now it came this issue brief which we
released in november or just before
christmas
and which is now also gone in as a
submission to the ongoing discussions
for the
food system summit 2021
so i will now talk a bit more about
what's in this
paper but of course i can only touch on
some of the things
and we're working on a longer uh much
more in-depth version that hopefully
will be
published in a couple of months
but what are some of the issues that we
see it from a from a planetary point of
view
a global scale view so the first one
is this one here which is you know is it
possible in the future the decoupled
growth
in agricultural production or
productivity goes
from the growth in fertilizer
consumption which is one of the issues
in terms of needing to overcome this
global nutrient imbalance
so what we have is a situation that
you can see this on this graph here
that the upland nitrogen input in this
case just for coupling
the orange circles has risen fast
and the gap to the corporate nitrogen
output
has remained large or even going a
little further
and so the surplus keeps going on a
global scale
and so then the question becomes if this
would continue for many more decades and
then of course we continue adding
more to the surplus more to the nitrogen
excess
loads and anything that comes along with
that from an environmental point of view
so is it possible to in the future
be couple that in those places
where there is excess use and
essentially reallocate some of this to
those places that made it
the second issue that we put up front is
africa
what what does it take to double
or triple crop yields in africa with an
increasing and balanced
use of nutrients so this is data from
from our own
nutrient use database at ifa where we
have
done nutrient budgets on a national
scale basis for the whole world since
1961
um what you can see there is uh this is
for literature phosphorus and the
potassium
for the whole of africa
we have essentially a situation that
crop removal by
far by far for all of these uh
exceeds the input that comes from
fertilizer manure usually
and a little bit of knives and fixation
so this leads down to
high looking or apparently high looking
nutrient use efficiencies if you
calculate them as
outputs or inputs
but what these actually represent if you
get efficiencies of
greater than one then you're mining the
soil
and that's what's happening in africa so
for us
this is a massive issue the average
total use of mpnk
in sub-saharan africa is now about 20
kilos
per hectare in terms of all nutrients
together
and only four or five countries exceed
50 kilos
not including south africa so they have
a long way to go
there and these nutrients can simply not
come from any other sources
because those don't exist either you
know so africa
is from a nutrient point issue uh
undoubtedly the biggest challenge in the
world
in the paper we discuss
briefly eight other issues and then i
have time now to go for each of those
but
them
new kind of data driven technologies and
business solutions
that may finally lead to more
precise nuclear management solutions
then we
all know or in other ways would use
nutrient glosses and waste along the
whole arcade food chain
how can we close the nutrient cycles in
crop and livestock farming in particular
what can really be done to improve soil
health
already starting with a better
definition of it i guess
how we should manage crop nutrition in
changing climates
there's both positive and negative
interactions associated with that
what are some realistic targets for
reducing further related
greenhouse gas emissions not being
talked about and what's actually doable
how can we design copic systems to
deliver higher quality more nutritious
food
and then the last one is very much about
the needs to
better monitor nutrients and
through that also track things and
achieve higher levels of
sustainability stewardship across the
whole chain
so we then
went on and tried to come up with a
general
disk definition of what they mean this
responsible bond material or new
paradigm for this
so and that's written here so first of
all it needs to follow a
food systems and circular economy
approach
so really that more holistic thinking
and within that uh incorporate
an array of know-how from different
disciplines
and directly and indirectly
the production utilization and recycling
of mineral nutrients in these systems
and through that hopefully achieve more
integrated targeted blood recreation
solutions that minimize all of these
trade-offs between productivity
environment and health
and on top of that they have to be
viable in the farmers and business world
different regions so that's roughly
speaking what we mean
and we identified the
five uh overarching uh objectives or
aims of this
you can see them on the left here so
it's just a different way of expressing
what was said before
so we must ensure uh continued
productivity growth and efficiency
goals but also resilience to climate
pressures and other things
we do need to reduce emissions and our
environmental impact
we do need to achieve the nutritional
health
we do need to achieve better soil health
and we have to massively increase the
nutrient recovery and recycling from
many different waste
streams so if we were able to achieve
all these
five things then i think we on the whole
would have much more sustainable form of
nuclear
management across the world and then
we looked at the six actions
and i'm going to talk about these
actions now a little bit more for the
rest of my part
yeah so i thought this is the first one
uh sustainability driven nutrient
policies and business models
that need to be tailored to specific
food systems in every country
and what this really means is that one
needs to recognize that the targets and
the roadmaps
for managing youtube will vary usually
depending on a country's precision
whether where the country currently is
in terms of regional jews and use
efficiency
and where it could be for that good for
that reason than
within it is our time frame
this is a craft that is sometimes shown
as a
to illustrate this so you can think of
the evolution
in three sort of stages in
terms of nutrient use efficiency
in a crop or hydrogen use efficiency in
particular calculators
the ratio of output over input so
typically
uh when we have very little use
of a fertilizer or neutral input and so
on the x-axis is expressed as relatively
low crop yield
and low economic development we also
tend to have high use efficiency and
that's the situation
that we have in africa but it actually
means the mining of nutrients or
nitrogen from the soil in this case and
as countries intensify
and also progress along the economic
development
usually we see an increase in nutrient
use which
leads to a decline in efficiency an
increase of the surplus the red line
and followed by a period c
where then technology improvements
policy and regulatory
pressure come in to finally create the
necessary incentives to do better
and as a result of that nutrient use
efficiency rises again
and the prices decline i've indicated
roughly
where some of the world's major
countries uh or new gen consuming
countries and regions is on this curve
right now uh
but what it makes clear is that we are
in the very different situations
in all of these regions therefore when
we think about
target roadmaps policies plans
investments
these will differ quite a bit it is also
important
to remember that there are practical
limits to both the nutrient juice
efficiency
and the surplus that can be achieved so
you cannot hope
that it will go down to completely zero
for the surplus and to one for the
efficiency because that is
often physically or biophysically
not desirable or possibly even one of
the implications of this is that
to do this and also then to get a better
handle on target setting
one really needs to have these
indicators
and this is one that i've been part of
the european united expert panel a few
years ago we
we set ourselves to ask can we come up
with a simple
indicator for nitrogen use efficiency
that is based
on all of the inputs at the farm gate
and outputs that go in
that are of importance for the overall
nuclear balance also in terms of what
then
are the consequences for air and water
influences and can we then find
a way to express this indicator in a
meaningful way that this also then
enables us to specify desired ranges
so what you can see here is that an
output is essentially the equivalent of
crop yield
and then input is fertilizer and manure
and other things
and uh from a crop point of view
from a nutrient point of view we would
like to be in this wide range here
anywhere in this desired range which
would represent
the best combination of high hydrogen
use efficiency this is a 90
line here combined with
high yield and relatively
low risk of nitrogen activation surplus
and also no risk of mining the soil
so this is still a little bit too
complicated to understand often also to
communicate and so but you can
simplify this message then also for
uh then you talk to farmers and
policymakers into
these three crop production solids so if
you're not getting the united states
efficiency is over 90 then obviously
you're mining the store and do something
to avoid this
if you're in the 50 to 90 range this is
quite desirable
and you're probably quite balanced um
but if you there's also a range
if you're lower than 50 very definitely
inefficient you got to do much more
about optimizing your nitrogen
application
so i'm just throwing this as one example
for the kind of
relatively simple but of the
scientifically quite sound
indicators that we need
to then also have the ability to accept
more differentiated
targets and interventions is what i
showed here in the previous
graph i'm sorry it was for uh
top production but you would already
have
different ranges for uh crop livestock
system
or for grassland the
second action is one that i've spent
probably
most of my own scientific career on and
that is really
how to get knowledge driven solutions
and novel technologies
that in theory should enable us to
tailor mutant formulations and
applications to local needs
in a much more convinced manner but how
to upskill those to millions of farmers
this is always the thing that has eluded
us we
have usually been able to come up with
interesting things
but then to scale those up into
digitally supported advisory systems
and make them really integrated business
solutions
is probably one of the biggest
challenges now i have
two pictures here on the side and one is
the load and dry systems in asia you can
see the smaller fields
and the other one is from some upland
systems in
africa and you see the same kind of
variable petals you know
so but of course the solution for each
of these systems will be probably quite
different
you can still probably follow certain
similar scientific principles at least
now this brings us then to essentially
the question of
how to make this part of the
precision economy approach that in which
you get need to get these small details
right to make a big difference
and at the end you know i keep when i
talk about these things i always say
okay there are really only
10 to 20 specific management decisions
in a crop cycle
that from an argonautic point really
matter
in in these nine categories that
i've listed there are strategic
practices that one way or another
require a change in behavior
and if you can change and support this
change in behavior by
coming up with the right kind of data
metrics and targets for each of these
decisions
and the ability to implement each at
high quality in the field
then you will have a successful
ergonomic
system so the problem i think is that
many of us have been working on
individual components of this
and it'd be very difficult to bring all
this together
into the bigger picture and then also
come up with the tools to really
support this so my own work on this
started in the early 1990s at erie on
many countries in asia
when we developed this concept of
science-specific nutrient management for
smallholder farmers
first and rice but later than outside
wheat
maize and now it's actually been done
particularly in china for over 20 crops
following very much the same approach
that
that we came up with in the 1990s
so you can see that conceptual approach
on the right so you
you have to wonder another in a crop
rotation or a cropping system make
pre-emergence and
post emergent decisions on managing
nutrients
under governing forces on those from the
outside
besides the more system in
in build determinants so
this becomes a complex decision process
for any farmer to do
and if if you've ever grown a crop
yourself
i can assure you it's not easy to make
these decisions
i've had a habit of growing from my foes
and erie
and laid out alternatives that every
year because i wanted to know
how to do these things and i would say
in 50 of the years i got it right and
the other 50
i didn't yeah even by using
pretty sophisticated scientific
knowledge and a few tools that i have
so what this work has shown over 25
years
is that in major crops like rice wheat
and maize
these are the benefits that we can
typically get 10 to 20
more yield in profit 10 less nitrogen
further allows the use
30 to 50 percent higher efficiency less
greenhouse gas emissions
uh nutrient mining investors disease
problems
we have a paper meta analyzer this work
right now
in submission which has come up these
these numbers and so
what i would say is that this is pretty
robust performance
under very diverse farming conditions in
asia and africa
so you won't find too many things that
can
give you this performance and there's
been families of software apps
that developed to support this the aries
family of
our live stock manager for different
countries
and ipni on the formerly ibn ios family
of newton experts
software solutions for frequent crops
and countries
so a lot of good work has gone into it
but nobody has really been able to scale
this up beyond a few thousand farmers
basically
there are many reasons for this uh one
is probably
that the whole approach is still too
complicated
you're still needing a lot of data or
asking lots of questions until you come
up with a decision
other reasons or more of the kind okay
it's never been really integrated well
enough into
business systems so
and if you don't have businesses
supporting these things
then one way or another you just don't
reach the steel
the national extension systems tend to
be too weak to achieve all that
so there may be in some countries no
incentives to do better
because the government is paying
unreasonable fertilizer subsidies for
example in india for many different
reasons
so one hope that i have and it may be
just a dream is that maybe we can
take some of the complexity out in the
future by
making these uh tourists
more like self-learning fertilizer
recommendation
and guidance tools throughout the life
cycle of a crop and for a whole cropping
system
so that's where i believe that
artificial intelligence and other
data-driven approaches can play an
increasing role
and so maybe allowing us one day to
go from the stage where we are at
present which is more of a descriptive
analytics and diagnostics approach with
a lot of
human interaction then all the way down
to
a more prescriptive analytics and
automatic decisions approached and
to make them possible take the human out
of the decision
out of the complexity so that it becomes
a simple
but robust ergonomic decision
then perhaps and one that self updates
over the over every year based on the
data collected then one may be
at a stage where these things are much
more scalable
maybe it's a dream but that's part of a
new paradigm to me
there are some new data sources that one
way or another could play a role
so one of my other headsets is mentioned
and we have released recently this new
30 meter resolution
particular storm up for the whole of
africa
so now this does not replace the need to
be in the field
because what you get there is a just in
any kind of mapping
approach an estimate for that 30 meter
pixel
and an uncertainty around this estimate
in this case because that's based on
example machine learning so but at least
it gives you perhaps one
level of resolution more that gets you
closer to the scale
where you would want to look at agronomy
more than just something for something
yeah so how to use this sort of type of
digital information and other stuff that
study is available
in the context of these self-learning
position forming solutions for smaller
farmers is for me
also another very exciting innovation
area in this new paradigm
we want to support this a bit and we've
just created
a little new consortium which we call
the consortium for precision crop
nutrition
i've often seen that people accumulate a
lot of data
or develop proprietary software or
algorithms that they don't want to share
with anybody
but these things never go anywhere than
on their own so i think there's a lot
more to
gain if we can create
more open innovation platforms in which
it is possible to
share data and work together in a
pre-competitive mode
so this is what this is on what i call
here the core operating system
for methods data and digital tools for
making
good and reproducible fertilizer
decisions
the problem right now is that if you
give 10 people
the same kind of data you will get 10
different further recommendations and
you still don't know which one is better
and that's really in this day and age an
embarrassment for the whole
community in my opinion so we've created
this consortium we've just launched it
we have a 28 members so for eight from
industry
nine cg centers and eight universities
research institutes and three others
so we're we've started now
discussing what we're actually going to
do in this space but it's one of these
mechanisms that i hope can
help us to accelerate innovation in that
phase
reduction is on cop livestock
integration
and greater levels of neutral recovery
and recycling from multi-billed waste
streams
so there is an ideal idealized
picture here which i redrew from another
one that was in a paper in
global food security last year two years
ago
so where we really ideally would like to
have
more integrated crop livestock systems
in which animals are being used for what
they're good at
for eating grass for example yeah in
which all of the waste
from crop production and inverters from
the
consumer side or from other industrial
steps in between goes back into the
system
and is reutilized so minimum losses of
waste
or or maximum recovery and therefore to
far less impact on water and air and
other environmental features
we think there is a massive opportunity
here from from the point of
view of new technologies that are being
piloted already
phosphorus recovery for example
in the uk i worked a lot with a small
company that processes
pretty much all slaughterhouse waste
into a granular mineral fertilizer of
your liking you know
these types of innovations and some of
our member companies
have also formed partnerships for that
already
so the yara for example has a
partnership viola with violia they
think they are the world's largest race
processing company
and icl has a similar partnership in the
netherlands
so big area it requires a lot of
innovation a lot of good sites but also
the necessary policy incentives
to close nutrient cycles but it could
lead to significant
reaction and new nutrients beginning to
end of the system
if we get system level efficiency up
through these
the mission sensitive agriculture is the
fourth action
and from our point of view in this new
paradigm it is really
focusing on the targeted enrichment and
application of fertilizers to deliver
micronutrients of importance to crop
animal and human health but this is
where the food system do comes in so
we're not just interested in
essential crop mediums anymore we really
think we need to think about crops as
carriers of leucine
for animals and humans and so higher and
zinc
zelenium and iodine play a significant
role
so there's been various studies of this
and partnerships
and i want to go through this but you
can see an example for iodine on top
here
where essentially through
potassium nitrate and iodine sprays it
is possible to represent really increase
the either in concentration of
wheatgrain
and with a relatively modest effort
if you and look at this
how this translates from a single farmer
doing this producing
big tons of grain another one and a half
hectare
essentially improving the iron supply of
25 people for a year for a whole year
through the flower that is being
produced of this
these are different calculations you can
make
the issue there is two one
uh where is this needed and why
targeting needs to be clear
and not just sort of doing it for
whatever reasons
you know how to mainstream this so who's
going to pay for this
it's very easy or relatively easy to
essentially say okay all fertilizer
needs to contain
selenium like they did in finland about
20 or 25 years ago and massively
improved the selenium status of the
refinished population
that's a political decision but
in the end it's mainstreaming either
from a political
or from a business point of view and
that's where a lot of these good
solutions that are available now from an
autonomic
fortification point of view doesn't
really move for it
the fifth action that we identified is
uh well duplo is one of course there's
still a lot of potential to
make fertilizers that are just smarter
and
better and there is a lot of interest in
this of course and
all the way down to things like nano
turtle devices which
i think wondering how they actually work
you know but
obviously that's an innovation area
that's common but the other one is
really
to change the whole
carbon footprint of the fertilizer chain
so and there we have
a number of opportunities to on the
production side
but also on the use side
i'm not going to talk about the palmer
carbon programs that
yara and lieutenant have just recently
announced whether they want to pay
farmers
for sequestering carbon in their search
for good practices and
actually see this as a new business area
so carbon credit payments
but this area here is very interesting
so
blue and green ammonia as a production
technology
so the blue ammonia is essentially low
carbon footprint ammonia
where through various means you just
reduce the
carbon footprint of the
of the oil process whereas in green
ammonia you use renewable energy
as your energy source and the
electrolyzes of nerve
and essentially you can create the zero
carbon uh ammonia what
inside the industry most is not just
reducing the carbon footprint of the
fertilizer
but using this new green or
low carbon ammonia has a new power
source for the hydrogen economy in the
world
it can use existing infrastructure for
storage and transport
and therefore it can also become a very
interesting
uh source for example a shipping fuel so
there's a lot of pilot projects in this
area
uh and the first big super tankers are
being built
that will be running on these types of
things so
this is a whole new area right now if
you look at the
global fertilizer production 20 percent
of the ammonia that is being produced
goes already into industrial
applications of various kinds so
this becomes another big chunk
then essentially a lot of this
will be part of the energy revolution
there are energy transformation the
decarbonizing
energy systems not necessarily
part of fertilizer industry anymore
and then the sixth action is very dear
to my heart
and i'm going to show a few examples of
of this kind and this is innovation so
i unless of course the need for
generally
higher investments in the whole
convention area
it's been an industry which
traditionally has a very low
levels of r d investment compared to for
example the protection seed sector or
life sciences industries
you know they're very good figures and
there are some exceptions in companies
but on
average the fertilizer industry uh
traditionally has spent less than one
percent of its revenue on r
d so whereas in crop protection c
sectors you would be talking more like
10 to 50
or in some cases closer to 20 we have a
long way to go
in the private sector and we also have a
long way to go in the public sector
because
i think funding particularly for more
applied plant nutrition research
has dwindled in many parts of the world
for decades already
so there is this uh but there's also i
think in my view
the need to change the way we do science
yeah so that we can actually do stuff
that is more meaningful without stifling
a
really fundamental science but also then
translate things
faster into practice so i've spent a lot
of time
also due to my roles at erie and then
later ross and i thinking about this
because
we do everyone does very interesting
science
but most of it ends up just in
scientific papers or conferences
or discussion groups and never sees
the light of performance feared so i
think we can learn a lot in my view
from lean innovation concepts
that are more typical for
the more entrepreneurial startup culture
the graph on the right is actually taken
from the agile bio foundry
which is essentially the consortium of
doa funded
fire labs in the us so
they got together a few years ago to
implement
this kind of strategy in their
world where they felt that none of them
had all of the resources to do the
entire cycle and therefore it was better
to work
together and utilize each other's
facilities so that you could build
test learn or design build test and
learn
much more quicker and actually also be
able to scale up
so if you want to scale up for example
you need the right kind of part of the
facilities which many don't have you
know what some have you know
so this kind of rapid innovation cycles
in which you learn quickly but you also
fail
quickly when necessary i admit this
we don't like to fail in science and i
don't even publish this often
but in the innovation world it's
perfectly fine to fail because it leads
you to on a different path
very quickly so i've been thinking a lot
about how to
incorporate these things into
the science of a traditional
research institution or a university if
you wish
well rasmus that we for our own purposes
distinguished science and innovation um
this way
so science is about discovery ideas
generation
building the knowledge invention it's
about making something
and innovation is the process by which
you try to bring these things together
so your ideas your previous knowledge
and inventions
converting them into commercially viable
products
so that is then needed
if you want to translate things into
practice scale
and you need to have a survival business
model along with this
what i've often observed also in the
institutions where i've worked you know
be it
nebraska yuri or rossum said that
there's a lot of excellent science
but uh very poor innovation so this step
here is
one that scientists typically struggle
with
which they're either uncomfortable with
or they don't know about it or they
don't want to hear about it and nobody's
there to help them
so at ratham's that when i came to
russian state in
2014 uh
that was the situation and probably to
some extent still is
that but we had uh you know there you
have an institute which at that
point was 171 years old
and had established a massive reputation
for excellent research worldwide
and the first you also then have a
certain way of doing science in the
usual groups and disciplines and
but what i noticed is that there was a
lot of effects
in science but very little impact
and when i went around the uk and talked
to farmers
for industry and can you name one or two
things that have come out of russians
that that have helped you in your
business in the last 10 or 15 years
nobody could name anything
and i thought that was really bad
because i saw all this very cool work
being done by scientists you know so it
got stuck somewhere
and the problem was of course also that
the client's funding world has
changed and does not really support
calculation design
or any kind of applied stuff anymore
everything has to be excellent
and it also creates then the wrong
incentives
for scientists so what we did at ross
instead
i asked people to do a self-assessment
and this is one of the things that came
out of it you know
so besides me all of the answers on this
paper which we published in nature of
plants as a commentary
are scientists of different ages who
have spent most of their scientific
career at rasmussen only
a long time of it so and i asked them to
review a science area
which none of them was actually working
on bioeconomy
so what came out of this that they all
discovered that actually
a lot of the stuff that we do fits the
needs of bioeconomy
so we could actually be a great source
of innovations for this
but we would have to make quite some
potential changes
in our video research in our culture
what they concluded themselves so it was
actually quite an eye-opener and then
we went around and started thinking
about what are some
interesting models that we could
potentially steal from others
to our needs one place that inspired us
a lot was wetzest
in the netherlands the european center
for excellence or excellent for
sustainable water technology
so they really want to sort of be at the
interface of different scientific
disciplines you can see the theater
they have chemistry physics technical
kind of life sciences
so they have a fancy innovation facility
but essentially they have three types of
projects
imagination projects optimization
projects and foundation projects
and their portfolio they're aiming to
always have about
50 imagination pointers so these are
things that
are leading to the next technology
breakthrough
but 15 to 20 foundation projects so this
would be more
risky discovery science and then the
rest of the optimization kinds of more
incremental research that improves
something that already exists you know
that's their philosophy and they have
different research themes
and the key engine of this
are these types of more entrepreneurial
phd
everything is done through phd students
there
but they have a very interesting process
so they have a selection process very
rigorous here
which in involves the universities uh
people as well as the company people
that have a particular interest in a
certain
theme and brings together
ideas and then talent so you select for
both
and only if it passes through then this
phd project can
uh go each phd's project must have at
least
one company in it too you know or
something
besides the academic partner or partners
so
they have supervision from their
academic side they have companies
involvement directly um fancy shared
facility where everybody can get
the stuff they need and they embed in
this
a whole range of other supporting
measures for the students for personal
growth
getting the right kind of innovation
culture and understanding how things
work
the outcome than the usual scientific
papers
but a lot of applications and patents
too sometimes some
fill-out companies and the other output
is of course
a new kind of very clever
entrepreneurial student or scientists
so i can encourage you to look at the
website a bit more there's a lot more
information there
so i always thought that was very
inspiring and then we went and draw some
stuff
and created the own innovation
mechanisms
here's just one example so we called it
agreeable
agricultural research innovation et
cetera we got together with
three other universities cranfield
university college london and hartford
because these all had
scientific expertise and facilities that
we did not have
even though we had very good facilities
at rossum set and lots of stuff but
these have a lot of things we didn't
have
like you know we didn't we didn't have
an astronomy department or a physics
department
or a big computer science department you
know or a business school like pancho
you know but you need these types of
things if you want to work
in this more innovation-oriented manner
and then these are just three different
mechanisms the thought leaps is the main
one
where really these are just six months
project for earlier theater testing you
can get another phase but you need to
demonstrate why
and then you have other ones that we
created and this would be
the innovation student of the bets of
kind for which we created a whole bunch
of those too
so this is part of the culture change
fortress and they're continuing along
those lines
i haven't been there for over a year but
it was not
easy to embed this into the existing
structures
also because there was no funding for it
and we had to often
find new ways of accessing money but
interestingly
we're also able to get money from
venture capital for one of these
innovation accelerators
so i think institutions that work in
science should really look at this with
an
open eye and see how they can
really adopt some of these mechanisms
in addition or partially replacing the
traditional models of
how they work so it's clear that
when we wanted to implement this
new paradigm for plant nutrition it
needs to be
a coherent effort by many
actors the blue boxes in this graph are
the key actors that really need to do
something different
so it's the fertilizer industry of
course
that has perhaps the main responsibility
but of the farmers and the service
providers and prices
the trade of processors but even
retailers and consumers and consumers of
course could do a lot in terms of
eating better and wasting less so this
is the massive feedback mechanism there
you know
at all of these stages we have
various ways to reduce emissions
for waste or recover and recycle more
so not just in one or two stages it
happens everywhere
you bring them back into the system
either at the industrial stage or at the
farming state
you know big opportunities
we as scientists typically sit above
here and in the supporting gang
along with others that need to create
the
appropriate mechanisms and lots of
evidence
for this but i'm hopeful
that this more holistic view that
is now taken place
will maybe finally help us to make
faster progress
on some of these things in the class
the this is by the slide
in the paper we discuss a little bit
what would success look like and we
actually make nine
example concrete points of what what
would be
the big achievements one could imagine
uh
by 2040 so one human generation from now
so i'm going to skip those i'm not going
to explain them but
what essentially the outcome should be
is in a societal plant nutrition optimum
and not just the pure economic planning
efficiency of them
the kind of that we had until now
so i think that's the new overarching
approach behind this and i'll be happy
to answer any questions now
johannes go ahead yeah yeah thank you
thank you very much for your career
well there is somewhere uh feedback yeah
now it's gone
um thank you for your uh for your
presentation
um i was wondering um you i was really
pleased
seeing that you mentioned circular
economy and and put a lot of emphasis on
on a new generation of um uh
fertilizers um i
i was wondering uh they're the
inconvenient
truth is that we are flushing more uh
nutrients down the toilets
um collectively speaking as we are
applying uh to agricultural fields and
many
many if not most countries in the world
um
so how uh with with your goal six
especially
how uh can we uh broach a conversation
with fertilizer companies that they
should actually more from a mining
company
to a recycling company to figure out how
we can recycle excreta from humans and
animals back to agriculture or is that
something that's already happening or is
this futile
it's already happening so we have just
three months ago we created a new task
force on neutron recovery and recycling
within ifa we never had this before you
know because
you know fertilizer and companies want
to would use new fertilizer and sell it
you know
but we have this now and uh when we
announce that
it raised actually a lot of interest we
have a lot of
team members and we've also created the
whole new committee called
sustainability
which we never had before you know so so
the interest is there
i think and we have a number of
companies who besides
mineral fertilizers already would use
commercial organic fertilizers or
organic mineral fertilizers
and there's quite a few who
are in exploring ways of
technologies for for recovering and
recycling
so at different stages of the production
process so that can range from
so if you're a phosphate mining company
like ocp
so you obviously want to reduce
the extent possible your waste at the
production of the mining and processing
stage
and you want to find the use for
phosphor gypsum which
sits in big pots millions of tons
and it's actually another valuable
product so
by then other companies are focusing
more
on uh municipal waste streams
uh so that's what the yara viola
and the poor operation i think is mainly
about that that's steady waste
essentially you know
and and there are some i think that are
more into the question of
[Music]
what do you do with processing
my new or from large livestock
facilities
the irony with that of course is that
that works best
if you have very large concentrated
livestock facilities
which nobody really likes either
but in the european union there is a new
standard being discussed called renewal
which is recovered nitrogen from manure
and something so the idea there is
basically
to make bulky
biomass waste into mineral great type of
fertilizers
yeah that is what you really need to
have a product that you can then utilize
much easier
out over longer distances
and that's where a lot of technology
comes in
i think we're still at the early stage
it needs a lot more investment
and there are also a lot of regulatory
uncertainties how to
how to regulate a product like this you
know including potential contaminants
and that sort of stuff
but the industry is definitely very
interested and i think this is one of
the big growth areas in the future
thank you thanks johannes
dominic you have a question
oh um sure i i actually lowered my hand
because it was kind of related to what
harness was asking so maybe i
was kind of covered but it's slightly
different so i'll go ahead because i
didn't see another any other hands
raised
um i'm just wondering a little bit about
how we balance
the fact that most of the decisions are
made at the farm level
and a lot of the tools we're looking at
with precision agriculture and
management
tools and looking at how we improve use
efficiency at the farm level
but doing that if you're looking at
improving recycling rates of nutrients
across
a whole food system is a very different
question
so for example if you're if you've got
doing nutrient recovery
you might have a lower nutrient use
efficiency for that recovered nutrient
than for a pure mineral fertilizer
so are we optimizing for the wrong thing
in driving farms to optimize
not use sufficiency when we should in
fact be optimizing across the whole food
system
for these nutrients and what sort of
tools can we do so make sure we're
getting the right answer
i think yeah i think in
i think we need both you know i mean
obviously
there's still a lot of room to
optimize nutrient use efficiency at the
farm scale and that should still be the
priority
i mean it depends a little bit i mean if
you're already at you know eighty
percent
in a very well managed uh system you
know there's not much to optimize
anymore
so but in other places you know you may
be at 30 percent then of course there's
plenty of space you know so
you know i i do i think we should not
lose sight of this this is really the
priority that's where after the bike of
the losses occur in the chain you know
at least those that directly and you
know hit the water and the air you know
so
i think that's right and i think the
recycling issue
is part of the more full chain nutrient
use efficiency thinking
and when people do food chain
calculations they usually conclude well
you know the food chain use efficiency
is very very low you know
now of course there's also many stages
in the food chain that are difficult to
address
i'm not even available here so how how
much realistically
of that further end of the chain you can
actually improve
compared to the beginning of the chain
the production and the
offline use was one of the open
questions to me myself
but i think it's we need both
all right thank you dominic thank you
akim uh so we are
we're over time now so i'm going to
close the
the the seminar as such and offer
akimar thanks and awkward to do this
uh on zoom but uh i know that your
presentation is deeply appreciated lots
of people
are writing about that thank you so much
um we're going to stay on i'll give my
no what time is it there for you now
it's it's
fairly complicated
so we're going to keep the the zoom open
for you know 20 minutes and a half an
hour just for
for some informal discussion so anybody
who would like to stay on for that
please please do so and uh thanks again
aki it was really
tremendous uh presence presentation give
us a lot to think about
why don't we take a two-minute break
just so that everyone can get up and
stretch and we'll reconvene here in just
a couple
minutes to continue the discussion
yeah thank you oh yeah great yes
refresh your tea okay thanks thanks a
lot that was really great i made some
notes on those docs those are all
available on the ifa website
the project reports um
most of it yes yeah sorry all right i
will circulate that
and anyway i can also send you the
powerpoint there are the links on it
then okay
fantastic uh so again everybody we're
just gonna
get up and stretch for a second
reconvene in in a couple minutes and
i'll come a few i want to give you
afford you a chance to stretch your legs
after
talking forever
i'm really i'm really ashamed i didn't
know about whetsus i mean
i'm a dutch citizen now so i should know
it but it's up in leovard and i didn't
realize it yeah
that that's really interesting i i
didn't know anything about that thanks
there's a very good place and um a very
interesting approach
yeah a very very stimulating approach
but it was in my back
well not different province so i guess
we don't count that but i should have
known about that i don't know why
i didn't believe thanks looking at their
website
by chance you know i didn't know about
it so one of my colleagues found it so
i can tim setter has a question for you
tim do you do you have your hand up
yes yes i do if i may please and
it's kind of a comment and just to see
what your reaction would be
um what what i would uh
suggest is that the messaging
about nitrogen is uh maybe
a little bit difficult for for many
people to
follow when you have a situation that
at the low end of the scale basically
nitrogen mining
gives you very high nitrogen use
efficiency
and at least you know my gut feeling is
efficiency is what we strive for
so i want the highest efficiency
and yet you show these graphs and they
show that in
situations where zero nitrogen is
applied you've got
very high efficiency because you're
measuring it as nitrogen in
or what is it nitrogen output over input
and then there's this sweet spot between
50 and 90 percent
that actually that's where we want to be
so
is there any better way to describe the
situation with nitrogen rather than
using this term nitrogen use efficiency
yeah um
i'm not sure i mean there are there are
many different definitions of knights
and use efficiency already yeah this is
just one
you know so you you probably find five
or six others and
more specific ones that deal with
fertilizer efficiency only you know so
uh and now not all of them
are much easier to understand either you
know
so i've i've become a bit sort of
complacent
about this in a sense to say okay you
know whatever it is
as long as we can find a way to explain
it you know
in some form you know and what we have
found with this particular indicator
okay i have to say this was developed by
a group
of art in europe and in europe you don't
have that situation that you have that
or very high efficiency because there's
no input
there's no there's always input so that
makes it easier
but um what we have found is that
the way we show this if you show people
sort of like a green zone where you can
be in or should be in you know
that resonates quite well and they're
using this now for example
also in discussions with the european
commission
who has set the goal as the as part of
the new farmer
uh farm to fork strategy for the eu they
want to
have nitrogen pollution in
the european union by 2030 they don't
exactly know what they mean with this
[Music]
but essentially that's that's the
political goal
and now we're using the efficiency
indicator
in the discussions with them to say look
you know
you need to use an indicator of this
kind or something like that
to really watch whether you're making
progress in a certain direction you know
if you just say let's reduce pollution
so what does that mean what product you
wear how much
are we starting with you know so so we
have found that it's actually be
useful for these purposes because it
feel
relatively simple but i i agree uh
problem lies at the at the african end
of the curve you know
where you seem to have massively high
efficiencies
which is actually the exact opposite of
what you
want so i have not found a better way of
expressing this
i think it's fine as long as you have
the opportunity
to explain uh as you did in the seminar
that these high efficiencies in the
african case
are due to in effect a mining of the
soil
and that's not desirable as long as you
have that ability to do that but
i don't know i'm afraid in some sound
bites
you know you may not have the
opportunity to do that so
it'd be nice if there was a better way
but i appreciate the problem
it's interesting when you when you look
at some of the
let's say for example how people have
tried to implement
a sustainable development goal 2 and
come up with an indicator for nutrients
they they often use and the implicators
which are far worse which is fertilizer
used as a hood you know
what does that mean
so so that makes it into
those things you know even the
rainforest alliance as a big
ngo which has a sustainable agricultural
stratification program with companies
and about two and a half million farmers
enrolled in this in the world
you can buy sometimes stuffed cocoa
coffee which has the
rainforest alliance label on it in that
standard
the indicator for nutrients use is
further demand per hectare
know no i don't know how they rate this
you know is
is it better if you dump on a lot
but that has made it into a sustainable
aggregate culture
because they didn't know better so i'm
having a discussion with them right now
to say look you can
probably do this better you know
yeah these are simple things that you
sometimes come across
where you wonder you know where a lot of
the even the scientific knowledge that
we have
just haven't made it into these things
you know
thank you very much can i make a quick
follow-up um
question on that which is to use the
brazil example i think there's another
angle to this as well which is doesn't
quite come out looking at the africa
versus
europe which is in brazil i think you've
got 80 of your nitrogen is coming from
fixation because you've got so many
legumes in the system um
so in that case you can have a very high
apparent
nutrient use efficiency without mining
and it's so the fixation
element needs to come into the metric as
well and that could be
that could be a big player so i think
again i think we need to be even more
careful than just saying it's a question
of whether you're mining or
not extinction is accounted for as an
input in that indicator
so okay but of course you
you never really know what exactly it is
you know
it's but it's in there yeah it's in
there already okay
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu